hey it's not my intro how's it going
bros my name is Pam welcome to another
episode of I weird stuff
[Music]
today is a very special day we have five
items the last one I've waited for
[ __ ] months to get I blew so much
money on this [ __ ] it's gonna be awesome
October's coming up I've got the perfect
outfit for you here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
so creepy can you even hear me what's
wrong with my eyes I don't understand
look at this leave it this is [ __ ]
terrifying
look at this [ __ ] okay well who came up
with this are you proud of yourself no I
don't like it
we got item number two which you can
combine with item number one it's boob
pillows
but I guess you wear them
does it look natural to make it even
more disturbing you can combine it with
the man I know how I'm gonna explain
this to my kids when I'm older there's
just no way you can combine these two
with a third idea which was sent to me I
don't know how they find my address it's
a little weird but it's from gift Oasis
hey how's it going
we recently launched a new range of
pussycat panties and we thought of you
thank you thank you so much thank you
[Music]
that's good that's that's really good
thank thank you thank you
well I guess I'll wear them looks good
[Music]
what how did this happen we were in
another video and now we're here I have
traveled through space and time to cut
up with sponsor eagle and he gave me
this package
isn't that right sponsor Rico this is
George your wisest you are an eagle now
this Mo's lootcrate
is
summon these change every month the 19th
so if you want the next theme or this
one order it before or after the 19th
the next theme will be time get it cuz
you're running out of time to buy one
sponsor you'll paid me to say that okay
we're opening I already love this this
is the greatest this is the greatest
package so far there's a freaking pic
achoo hat with poke balls
what else do you want in life I don't
know what is this the Simpsons what is
this I am confused
we got a hearthstone hearthstone squeaky
stone I love hearthstone oh [ __ ] yes Oh
No this supernatural car the car from
Supernatural like me I should say I love
Dean so much I love supernatural so much
I wish they would just [ __ ] already ok
ooh
a free card pack in hearthstone our love
horse to the science of future is great
well the Hat was clearly the best one if
you're interested in loot crate check
out loot crate calm slash boots and if
you add the code payouts you got 10% off
what more do you want in life a Pikachu
hat that's right go check it out
now the fourth item I don't understand
but it's a bondage beer it is kind of
cute
let's that's literally it you can buy a
bondage beer if you want I does it have
anything underneath it does okay that's
so [ __ ] weird what would you do
why would why a gag ball why I don't
like it it's time for the rocket boots
all right let's just get this [ __ ] over
I got him here I'm so excited they
recommend that you try them indoors
first so I'm just gonna do that I'm a
little scared and by a little scared I'm
a lot of scared I'm many scared
oh god they're not even on Jesus Christ
God I'm scared I'm legit scared
[Music]
Wow how in the hell
[Music]
[Music]
so you have to do like a sprint to
stardom
I'm sweating oh man oh hey all right
well thank you for watching this video
if you enjoyed leave it a thumbs up and
I'm gonna I'm gonna stop bro fishing and
I'm just gonna kiss you I'm kidding
Jesus Christ remember you can buy your
look right on the 19th of each month
from loot crate comm forward slash cubes
and use the cope use to get 10% off I
don't understand
did this looks again